I had a sort of a it was like a plot for  a science fiction novel that I was  thinking about last week I realized when  the when the network becomes sentient  what will it do with all these human  beings because it will analyze the  situation and realize that the human  beings pose a threat to the integrity of  the planet but it will also analyze the  situation and realize that the source of  its own evolutionary advance requires  keeping these biological units in the  loop because of their creative ability  in writing code so then I was imagining  a world where they would call everybody  but the code drivers and you would have  a world of a hundred million code  writers sustained in incredible luxury  while the robots go about repairing the  damage to the planet and planting  forests and cleaning up the rivers and  so forth and so on I don't know whether  that's a utopia and dystopia I guess it  depends on whether you're learning  [Applause]